este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
blind keys seguro que al igual que me
pasa a mí muchas grabaciones tienen la
sensación de que no tienes tanto tiempo
como te gustaría para leer que si
exámenes que si trabajo que si
compromisos en fin al final siempre
siempre hay algo que se acaba
interponiendo pero y si te dijera que
existe una app que te reduce miles de
libros de no ficción en inglés a 15
minutos de lectura y ojo no solo en
texto sino también en formato de audio
lo que por un lado nos viene genial para
hacer oído con el inglés y por otro hace
que sea muy cómodo porque puedes
utilizar esta aplicación en casi
cualquier lugar está por ejemplo en todo
el tiempo que perdemos en el metro en el
tren en el bus etcétera etcétera pues
bien esta app existe y se llama bling
east con ella vais a descubrir un mundo
de posibilidades libros de inversión
política economía ciencia cuando te
quieres dar cuenta te habrás estampado
una biblioteca entera y en la comunidad
de visual política estamos de
enhorabuena porque en los primeros 100
de vosotros que vayáis a bling is
puntocom
tendréis acceso ilimitado por una semana
para
totalmente gratis sí oye por lo que sea
no os convence podéis cancelarlo sin
problema durante esos siete días y en
caso de que os guste pues disfrutaréis
también además de un 25% de descuento
para un full member sí gracias a bien
kits por ofrecer esta oportunidad a
nuestra comunidad y por apoyar también
nuestro proyecto y sin más arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
si no ha tomado una decisión acabar con
el estatus libre de hong kong
[Música]
a finales de mayo de este 2020 la
asamblea popular nacional el máximo
órgano legislativo de la república
popular china votó por implantar en hong
kong una nueva ley de seguridad que le
dará al régimen chino la posibilidad de
perseguir discursos ideas y mensajes
políticos en la hasta ahora ciudad
autónoma una ley que también permitirá
que la dictadura china despliegue sus
servicios de seguridad e inteligencia en
hong kong para poner fin a cualquier
síntoma de disidencia en esta imagen
estoy viendo en la pantalla
el propio xi jinping está votando a
favor de esta ley esta imagen es el
reflejo de como china está devorando
lentamente a la otrora conocida como
perla de oriente no me puedo imaginar
vivir bajo la sombra de la policía
secreta parece que el último cortafuegos
que protege nuestras libertades está a
punto de colapsar
alan un estudiante universitario hong
kong es en declaraciones al asia nikkei
review se está descomponiendo por
completo el modelo de un país dos
sistemas que se le había garantizado al
pueblo de hong kong este es el período
más triste de hong kong no tengo
palabras para expresar la sensación de
desesperación que tenemos
denis kwok miembro pro democrático en la
cámara legisla
con busquets fans de hong kong exploran
la salida a medida que se avecina la ley
de seguridad nacional amigos este es un
tema en el que invitó al político nos
preocupa especialmente es algo de hecho
de lo que ya os hemos hablado en un
reciente vídeo aquí en el canal pero nos
quedó una pregunta pendiente cómo ha
reaccionado la comunidad internacional
ante lo que supone el principio del fin
del que hasta ahora era uno de los
territorios más libres del mundo pues lo
cierto es que por lo general la condena
internacional ha sido tan clara como
tibia tibia porque en general no se ha
concretado en prácticamente nada
[Música]
hasta ahora el país que más ha puesto el
grito en el cielo ha sido estados unidos
que ha amenazado con dejar de considerar
a hong kong como un territorio autónomo
lo que podría suponer que algunas de las
ventajas que tiene esta ciudad en sus
relaciones con eeuu desaparezcan
próximamente
hablamos de privilegios como los
aranceles reducidos el libre movimiento
de personas y capitales un acceso casi
ilimitado a la tecnología norteamericana
e incluso la ausencia de restricciones a
los intercambios con el dólar
[Música]
se cultivan con armas
eso sí hasta el momento ha limitado su
amenaza al aspecto comercial lo que a la
hora de la verdad tendría poca
relevancia porque las exportaciones
directas de hong kong a eeuu son
pequeñas sin embargo eeuu no es el único
país que está tomando medidas de hecho a
pesar de la tibia respuesta
internacional y más allá de la
aplicación de sanciones que sobre todo
que castigarían al propio pueblo de hong
kong se han puesto sobre la mesa algunas
medidas ingeniosas amigos se puede
salvar a hong kong atentos
la metrópoli hong kong 2.0
vamos a ver si hay un país que tiene una
responsabilidad particular respecto a lo
que pueda ocurrir en hong kong ese es
precisamente el reino unido- al fin y al
cabo casi la mitad de los con con eses
nacieron cuando hong kong aún formaba
parte de la corona británica y eso es
precisamente lo que ha hecho que el
gobierno británico haya tenido que
pronunciarse para que de una forma muy
diferente a la de los eeuu atentos a
este titular porque por aquí van los
tiros 3 de julio del 2020 boris johnson
se compromete a emitir en el reino
unido- a 3 millones de personas
procedentes de hong kong si habéis
escuchado bien la primera reacción de
las autoridades británicas ha sido poner
sobre la mesa una especie de salvavidas
para todos los hongkoneses que puedan
llegar a sentirse amenazados por el
creciente control de la dictadura china
y es que veréis tal y como todos sabéis
hong kong fue parte del reino unido-
hasta el día 1 de julio de 1997 fecha en
la que se consumó el traspaso de su
soberanía a manos chinas
sin embargo a pesar de formar parte del
reino unido- hasta 1997 desde los años
60 los hongkoneses no tenían la
ciudadanía británica sino tan sólo un
derecho a solicitar lo que se conoce
como la nacionalidad británica de
ultramar un estatus que le otorga a
cualquiera de los aproximadamente
350.000 hongkoneses que cuentan con el
un pasaporte británico y la posibilidad
de usar los servicios de embajadas y
consulados de este país a lo largo y
ancho del mundo un estatus que sin
embargo lo que no les concede es el
derecho a vivir oa trabajar en el reino
unido
[Música]
pues bien lo que ahora ha propuesto el
gobierno de boris johnson es ir mucho
más allá por un lado reabrir la
posibilidad de que las casi tres
millones de personas que nacieron en
hong kong antes de 1997 puedan volver a
solicitar este estatus por otro mejorar
los derechos que lleva aparejados veréis
la idea que ha puesto solamente al
gobierno es que ahora este estatus de
nacional británico de ultramar permita a
todos sus titulares quedarse en el reino
unido durante 12 meses que puedan
solicitar fácilmente poder trabajar y
estudiar el país y que este plazo de 12
meses pueda prorrogarse sin ninguna
dificultad y no sólo eso la idea
manejada por el gobierno británico
pasaba por que esta figura se convierta
también en un camino cómodo un atajo
para alcanzar la plena ciudadanía
británica su china continúa por este
camino ya aplica esta legislación de
seguridad nacional lo haremos
permitiremos que los titulares de
pasaportes nacionales británicos de
ultramar vengan al reino unido- y
soliciten trabajar y estudiar por
periodos prorrogables de 12 meses y que
a su vez les proporción
un camino a la futura ciudadanía
dominique rap ministro de exteriores del
reino unido- es decir el reino unido-
está poniendo sobre la mesa toda una vía
de escape pero es que acaso en londres
están pensando en que de repente cientos
y cientos de miles de hongkoneses hagan
las maletas y se muden al reino unidos
pues no evidentemente no sin embargo de
completarse esta iniciativa la mayoría
de los hongkoneses tendrían una vía
inmejorable para escapar de los excesos
del gobierno chino es decir cualquier
hong kong es con este derecho podría
escapar fácilmente siempre que lo
estimase oportuno sin tener que pasar
por los complicados trámites de pedir
asilo político por ejemplo si tal y como
parece querer el gobierno chino su
control sobre hong kong y las libertades
de los con con eses se recrudece muchos
políticos empresarios disidentes o
incluso estudiantes podrían en cualquier
momento mudarse a un refugio seguro con
todas las garantías y no sólo eso al
mismo tiempo supondría todo un incentivo
para que el gobierno chino nos llegue a
cruzar ninguna línea roja porque de
hacerlo podría provocar toda una fuga de
cerebros y capital humano
[Aplausos]
hablamos por cierto de una estrategia
que tiene precedentes a finales de los
años 60 y principios de los 70 el
dictador ugandés y el gobierno de kenia
expulsaron a decenas de miles de
personas oriundas del sur de asia que en
muchos casos tenían pasaporte británico
ante esta situación en 1972 el gobierno
británico del conservador edward heath
listo posible que miles de estos
refugiados pudieran establecerse en el
reino unido- casi 30.000 personas
siguieron este camino dando lugar a una
de las cohortes de inmigrantes que más
éxito social y económico han tenido en
el país
[Música]
amigos amigas estamos ante una ingeniosa
solución que dadas las circunstancias
podría ser la mejor respuesta posible al
envite de china a diferencia de las
sanciones no sólo no castiga a los
propios componentes sino que está todo
un salvavidas y eso eso enfurecido mucho
a china
el gobierno de simple ya ha anunciado
que se opone frontalmente a esta medida
por supuesto ha amenazado con tomar
represalias y cuando pekín habrá de
represalias por supuesto habla de
represalias económicas lo que por cierto
plantea serias dudas acerca de si
finalmente londres llevará a cabo esta
jugada no olvidemos el peso que china
puede tener en la economía pues presido
en cualquier caso la pregunta que
podemos hacernos es pero si con el apoyo
de la comunidad internacional el
gobierno británico le diese este
privilegio a todos no son con eses no
sería una respuesta maestra a la
voracidad expansionista de xi jinping no
sería acaso una forma de convertir a
hong kong en todo un símbolo del
compromiso de los países libres en la
lucha contra la expansión del
autoritarismo
[Música]
pues aquí no termina todo se ha
planteado también otra idea una idea
mucho más original y que podría llegar a
suponer toda una revolución de llevarse
a cabo cosas que ya os adelanto no
ocurrirá pero que es interesante tener
en cuenta os imagináis que el reino
unido impulsará la creación de una
especie de nuevo hong kong en su propio
territorio
sí sí tal cual no se me de la olla a ver
es una idea que ha puesto sobre la mesa
el adam smith institute y que la verdad
no sería tan descabellada como puede
parecernos a simple vista
[Música]
siguiendo el ejemplo de la city y sobre
todo a la propuesta de johnson de
puertos libres de la que ya os hemos
hablado aquí en visual político el reino
unido podría habilitar en su territorio
un espacio en el que cualquier ciudadano
o empresa de hong kong pudiera
instalarse libremente un espacio que
tuviera unas regulaciones y un sistema
fiscal similar al que existe en el
propio hong kong un modelo mucho más
amigable para los negocios que los
modelos europeos
en otras palabras hablamos de crear una
zona económica especial que podría
llegar a convertirse en el mejor punto
de conexión entre asia y europa al
tiempo que le daría aún más opciones a
los hongkoneses y no no es un
planteamiento descabellado tener en
cuenta que alguna parte del éxito
económico del reino unido durante las
últimas décadas ha tenido que ver con la
city y las regulaciones especiales que
este país aprobó para la industria
financiera pues esto sería algo parecido
además para el reino unido- será una
forma de incrementar su competitividad
estrechar sus lazos con el continente es
ético y atraer empresas y capital humano
justo cuando más lo necesita tras haber
llevado a cabo el break si no creéis que
sería una jugada audaz
pero amigos hay otro país que también
está siguiendo muy de cerca todo lo que
acontece en la antaño conocida como
perla de oriente veamos quién es un
primo hermano inquieto taiwán o no quita
el ojo de los acontecimientos que se
están viviendo en hong kong es que en
taipei no tienen claro si el gobierno de
seguir prince sale con la suya con hong
kong puede que su siguiente jugada sea
incrementar la presión hacia esta isla
una isla que se está convirtiendo en el
último refugio para muchos disidentes y
actores políticos que se niegan a hincar
la rodilla ante la dictadura china eso
es lo que explica por ejemplo que las
solicitudes de permisos de residencia en
taiwán por parte de hong kong es estén
creciendo como la espuma el número de
hong kong es es que solicita la
residencia se dispara el número de
ciudadanos de hong kong es es que han
solicitado la residencia en taiwán ha
crecido un 41 por ciento en el último
año claro que esto también entraña un
riesgo y en taipei tienen muchas dudas
sobre qué camino escoger me explico por
un lado tiene mucha simpatía por los
juncos
es que se han rebelado contra el intento
chino de incrementar su control sobre la
ciudad pero por otra parte no tienen
claro que cabreada el gobierno chino más
allá de la cuenta sea una buena opción
[Música]
de momento el artículo 18 de la ley
relativa a los asuntos de hong kong y
macao establece que el gobierno de
taiwán proporcionará la asistencia
necesaria a los residentes de hong kong
y macao cuya seguridad y libertad se
vean inmediatamente amenazadas por
razones políticas sin embargo en la
práctica esta ley no se ha desarrollado
y no está claro el proceso para tramitar
las solicitudes de asilo ni los plazos
ni el presupuesto disponible hasta ahora
el gobierno de taiwán no ha querido
abrir esta caja de pandora
precisamente por eso ahora la presidenta
chain win que como ya os hemos contado
en varios vídeos no es precisamente muy
amiga de pekín anunció a finales de mayo
la formación de un equipo de trabajo
para tomar una decisión definitiva y
concretar de una vez por todas los
derechos que tendrían los componentes
que soliciten asilo en taiwán en un
sentido o en otro y la pregunta que
podemos hacernos es debería la comunidad
internacional apoyar de forma decidida
al gobierno de taiwán para que taiwán se
convierta en el gran refugio ante el
autoritarismo y el creciente
expansionismo del régimen de xi jinping
esta es una de las preguntas que estos
momentos debía copar la actualidad
internacional
hong kong y es mucho más que una ciudad
en esos momentos se está convirtiendo en
todo un símbolo de por dónde pueden
discurrir las cosas durante los próximos
años amigos creo que una de las peores
cosas que pueden pasar es que los
problemas económicos hagan que el
gobierno chino le dé todo el
protagonismo a su agenda política en fin
amigos así están las cosas pero qué
respuesta crees que debería dar la
comunidad internacional ante la
creciente intromisión de china en los
asuntos propios de hong kong déjanos tu
respuesta aquí abajo en los comentarios
y si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle al botón
de like un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]